okay jesus [ __ ] crazy yeah just said
we just we lost everything just like
you're just all worked out
yeah i mean [ __ ] i went down there
restarted everything restarted and then
we'll see
only i can think of is that this area is
[ __ ] starting to grow real quickly
it's construction or they're just
they just keep
taxing the [ __ ] infrastructure
i kind of feel like that's probably what
it is because honestly it's not just
because you kept trying to say that it's
this laptop it's not um because i have
connection problems on all three of my
computers
um and we have it on the uh the tv as
well every now and then yeah every now
and then uh usually youtube sometimes to
be will uh kind of like cut off as well
but
i mean you know like i said we're not in
the middle of nowhere but
it is pretty rural and it is an area
that's kind of like growing a lot so
they're doing a lot of construction yeah
and we have the service that we have is
through our hoa
and
so they have wi-fi for all of their
communities yeah and i kind of feel like
maybe they don't have the infrastructure
yet like
and this is the best one out here this
is the best service out here yeah
because we tried like we tried yeah you
guys remember we had like two or three
others
didn't work where [ __ ] i mean we still
have hughes net as a backup because it's
satellite yeah and we still have the
satellite dish so in case like the other
[ __ ] gets knocked out we can at least
get online you can't stream with it
because it's way too [ __ ] slow but
you can't get information but you can
like use you know the regular internet
right but
i don't know it just makes me really
angry because i'm like i hate
like paying for something and it not
working the way that it's supposed to
work that just makes me very very angry
hughes net
as long as you got electrical power
you'll have internet
which that's good here because you get
hit by a hurricane
well that's why we figured because we
were just going to get rid of hughes net
even though
you would get penalized because you have
to have for two years they'll give you a
fine if you have it taken out but then
we were talking about it's like well
maybe it would be better to just like
pay for it every month in case
like you said in case there was a
hurricane or something like that and
we'd still be able to because we've had
our internet knocked out before because
i can just hook the generators up and
run the house you'd still be able to
communicate with the outside world right
because you don't require it doesn't
require any kind of infrastructure it's
directly to a satellite
although uh knowing our luck if we had a
hurricane it'd probably like blow the
satellites
and i'd be like well that was all that
money wasted oh well
yeah holy [ __ ]
uh
youtube isn't letting me send super
chats keeps giving me an error message
yeah i've never had that happen before
i wonder why
i wonder is it something to do with i
don't know because we got super chats on
wednesday didn't we a few
okay so it's so it's not that just that
i'm going through obs now instead of
actual youtube although this this
program is like hooked up to youtube
like it goes into my youtube account and
i'm seeing like the youtube chat and
everything yeah i just don't have
youtube open like i used to
yeah um so maybe i don't know maybe it's
like some kind of like glitchy kind of
[ __ ] oh dj maniac
yeah you missed it dj i was talking
about uh
some stuff that i saw on youtube last
night [ __ ] stuart hammer off and uh
uh
also got from
oh eric weinstein was talking to the
dude
that um did the stargate program for the
nsa and cia all that military remote
viewing if you watch the other video
later the one that the stream that fell
it's going to be it'll still be there
part one and i show the video that i was
talking about it's an hour long it's an
interesting show man they get into the
damn tic tac ufos
the guy said that he had better videos
of it he saw the classified videos of
the damn tic tac
and they were saying
but what was funny is that he's they
said why it looks so fuzzy he goes well
because it it was doing stuff that was
slightly outside
normal space time
um that's what he believed so it was
hard to get
hard to get an image of it says it's
gonna look real fuzzy
because it's warping space
and time
and he was talking about the way it was
moving and everything
weird [ __ ]
man it is weird yeah eric weinstein's
like nah
how can you say this
because i know you're a rational person
you're you know exactly what you're
talking about you're educated you're
like how could that be and he goes into
quantum mechanics and
reality isn't what we think it is
we are only
we only know
reality through our five senses and
that's not enough there's other
dimensions other spatial dimensions
other temporal dimensions
like
we know about going into the future
going across the line in the future but
then there's other probabilities that
are also happening and
maybe
he said there's a bunch of ways you can
cheat theoretically they had some
evidence of that
dj maniac's asking if we've considered a
twitch i have actually
i'm not entirely sure is there not a way
that you can simultaneously stream i'm
sure that'll i'm sure i'm sure our
connection will really like support we
that little like simultaneously stream
to youtube and twitch like at the same
time i thought that you could
but uh i don't twitch was a [ __ ] service
that you just get kicked off for
anything we'd get kicked out and we get
kicked well twitch was mostly started
out for gaming really i mean and that's
kind of uh but you know it's i don't
know it's something that i'll kind of
maybe i'll look into it but
zach says uh i'm mad i missed the lindy
chamberlain show i have a lot to say
there and the meryl streep movie is an
old fave yeah i actually had a good time
with that and we got a comment uh i
think it was from trey actually and he
said um you know i kind of knew about
that case but i didn't think that it
would be all that interesting like to do
a show about and he's like wow you guys
really proved me wrong that is a really
interesting case yeah and i said and the
you know the worst thing about it like
with the baby being eaten by a [ __ ]
dingo which is horrible enough but to me
the whole like [ __ ] show that followed
about her getting like accused of murder
and actually like going to prison and
[ __ ] like that was
a lot more
you know that that was a lot like worth
going into like on that show because you
know it kind of like said a lot about
what was going on at the time culturally
i guess
uh and dj maniac says and yeah the
reason the dingoes ate my baby meme
became a thing was because of street's
ridiculous dialogue and accent yeah i
kind of feel like it wasn't so much
people poking fun at the fact that a
baby had been eaten by a dingo which of
course is terrible but i think it was
because of meryl streep who is not
australian
doing an australian uh accent in that
movie i do like that movie a lot and i
think she did get an oscar nomination
for it i don't think she won but i think
she got an oscar nomination and i
remember really liking that movie but
i remember and i've seen it a long time
so please correct me zack uh i'm pretty
sure her australian accent was not that
good but
i could be wrong about that i couldn't
get wrong but i remember like even when
i saw it back in the day being like
you know what i mean
it'd be a little cringy
but uh you know
uh dj maydak said uh last podcast on the
left did it as an experiment for a while
with their live stream
oh oh oh
and we lost it again
great
what the [ __ ] is wrong with this [ __ ]
it's bad it's back i don't know what the
[ __ ] is wrong with this [ __ ] it's you
you're breaking it no i'm doing it i
tell pookie that she breaks it all the
time but she doesn't care
every time she comes in i'm like you're
breaking it pookie you're breaking the
internet and she's just like whatever i
do these these uh
look at that [ __ ]
well as long as it's not zero okay keep
talking okay i can't see it i can just
see the colors all right well you should
put your glasses on like because i
couldn't see it no it wouldn't matter
even if my glasses on i could i would
never see that really i can see my
glasses on as long as that's not like
it's bat okay you're a girl now women
have better eyesight than men in old age
although i will say i used to have
kick-ass eyesight because remember even
as as recently as like three or four
years ago you're like what does that say
like you you give me stuff to read yeah
um my eyesight started going like that
it was really quick like i think it was
maybe six months yeah and i could see
like
a [ __ ] gnat across the room six
months later i couldn't see my phone it
was just like a big blur
so you know so i had to get reading
glasses and i don't have like health
insurance or nothing so i can't like
afford to get
uh
contacts or anything like that so i just
keep getting
higher and higher uh
reading glasses from like walgreens yeah
i get i get full optical
i get full optical through through the
va and everything and there's really no
difference between
store-bought reading glasses and [ __ ]
what they're giving me it's it's
actually kind of [ __ ] i could get
one off the [ __ ] racks that work just
as good as these
i guess
i get a good deal on amazon i got a pack
of a five pack of these reading glasses
um for
20 bucks for a five pack and now if you
go to walgreens or cbs or something they
charge 20 bucks for one pair
uh but i found a five pack of course
over the years
um you know going to bars and things
like that and like sometimes i would
lose them
or they would get broken uh so i do
actually have two pairs left so i have
this pair and like one extra pair but
they're still like going strong i think
i'm still at two times magnification or
1.5 magnification or something like that
and i can see
perfectly fine with these on uh if i
take them off
um i can still see technically but
everything is just really blurry so i
can't really see uh i can't really read
anything that's on the thing
uh jason says loving the omen t-shirt
jen thank you very much yeah i love this
shirt and it's uh i got it from
i think i got it from busted tees was it
busted tees or no fright rags that's
where i got it busted tease is where i
got that catzilla shirt
um
but uh fright rags i got like a whole
bunch of like horror themed shirts a
while back and this was one of them
uh is your router wired to the computer
not not no not hardwired honestly i have
a lan cable and i have a
wi-fi booster the wi-fi booster is like
right there
and so i was thinking oh yay like i can
hook up the lan cable to the wi-fi
booster because it has a thing where you
can do that and like hook it up to the
laptop but it made absolutely no
difference no of course not because that
won't that doesn't that the signal will
be high but not the not the speed yeah
so it's like well we'd have to
physically get to that thing and i'd
have to route it all the way down there
i mean it might is it
it is very long but i don't think it'll
quite reach that land cable is like 30
feet long i wouldn't have ridden i don't
think it would reach now that would
probably make a huge difference if we
could actually put it right directly
into it yeah because that's how we used
to have it set up but this house is much
bigger yeah and it's like way the [ __ ]
down in the living room is where the
[ __ ] is um cheryl said that your butt
crack was [ __ ] with the internet [ __ ]
no that'd make it get sharper
the [ __ ] internet speed would speed
up it'd be getting like super broadband
if my ass crack was involved that [ __ ]
tom's butt crack is broadband [ __ ]
brian
can i make you a shirt
my ass crack is broadband would you wear
it it's because all of it you don't have
to wear it out you can wear it on the
show the internet it has so many
interconnections inside of it that's
it's damn near a sentiment it's like
it's like that thing for [ __ ] from
from the internet it's not for me for me
it's like that thing from the terminator
there's this guy saying skynet you know
the internet is that's kind of the
internet skynet's [ __ ] uh really
interested in in booty okay so wait are
you saying that your butt crack is
skynet skynet is interested in my booty
it would it would up the cable speed
so they could take a picture
every time it's on there [ __ ] people
that makes total sense yeah it's gay
skynet's homosexual
it's very interesting you heard it here
first
holy [ __ ] yeah
the inside of your head
well i just i'm we were talking about
twitch
twitch is for gamers
it's just obvious to me all these
[ __ ] internet
services that come out of silicon valley
are not
businesses
they're they've got to be government
funded wait where's xero all right see i
don't want me talking about that see
damn
come on really damn is it doing it
okay it's going back up it's coming back
up
nope what no but
what in the [ __ ] goddamn hell i don't
know
i don't know
yep wait wait
come on
let's try it okay ain't that some [ __ ]
jesus christ man it was like i can't
take it i can't take it that's the thing
this is like god this is like it's
[ __ ] painful it's painful wait wait
wait back
it's painful just watching it is [ __ ]
painful yeah
that's the [ __ ] crazy [ __ ] because i
feel like i can't like we get it like in
a flow going and then like that kind of
[ __ ] happens and i'm like i don't even
know if like people can still like
[ __ ] hear me or anything
but you know what are you seeing normal
granthar says
grantham says uh marilyn rice cub is
filming personalized messages on memo
for 75 dollars a pop
how about getting one for your podcast
you know get her little pouty face out
there promoting the show to the masses
i think she's single man i can we get
her over here
talking about
paying her for you knit [ __ ]
[Laughter]
she's not that cute
she might be watching this right now
maryland man
for you guys who don't know that's
that's my girlfriend yes uh from back in
back a long time ago yeah she's cool i'm
just i'm just [ __ ] driving her
just no she wants to [ __ ] sell some
[ __ ] messages and [ __ ] that's that's
all her i mean if you can get it i'm not
like [ __ ] on anybody i think she got
stephen's cigar they're all [ __ ] on him
i think she got divorced i think she got
divorced a couple years ago thanks oh
you've been keeping up with that huh no
i think she said something about it
oh i don't know i just i don't know
uh
mr eddie it says any thoughts on the
sherry papini arrest yeah i haven't
really finished man i hadn't really
heard much about that but well yeah but
he asked about that before like when you
were going off about the alien so i
wanted to like address that i don't know
enough about that to comment but i do
like kind of know what you're talking
about so
but that's one thing that probably yeah
what are you getting upset over there
yeah i was i was gonna say that these
these [ __ ] internet services like
twitch and [ __ ] they can't be
for profit businesses it's just like the
news media it can't be for profit they
would have long been out of business
which leads me to believe they're all
darpa funded or they're all uh they all
they're all getting tax
payer
uh funding and you know to to help keep
them alive
because every time they become popular
enough to make money
they they they stop that they don't want
to make money like
twitch started to become you know
booty adjacent it was just about it was
about thoughts girls
in bikinis inside their [ __ ] blow up
[ __ ] swimming pools in their living
room splashing the booty up and down and
they that made a [ __ ] ton of money but
twitch is like oh no we can't have this
they had to shut that down
i'm like who
you when they when they make business
decisions
that stupid you know it's all cia stuff
it's all intelligence gathering
stuff that's all that's all it is
the same with the news
it's obvious i mean they haven't told
the truth in [ __ ] 40 50 years it just
costed lies
and they don't have any viewers so how
the [ __ ] are they staying in business
[ __ ] a cia
it's just a way of pumping out
propaganda and getting information
putting information out and getting
information in that's all they are
but uh i couldn't believe that
twitch was making all that [ __ ] money
on young girls splashing their booties
up and down inside of swimming pools
and they were making a [ __ ] ton of money
the girls and the [ __ ] oh no we can't
have your thoughts making money
and then they want to talk about these
brave and empowered [ __ ] single women
and [ __ ] but then they don't let them
let them make any money
so yeah [ __ ] all that
that was ridiculous um
and and it was and they complied with
the terms of service it wasn't
nudity
and people were wanted to pay to see
that those girls were making good
business and people were flocking to the
platform yeah i mean i don't have a
problem with that because honestly like
yeah if you want to do porn there's porn
sites yeah but that's not porn because
it wasn't porn
it was just cute girls trying to make a
living on the [ __ ] platform and the
platforms were getting huge
and anytime anything's fun
they gotta cut us balls off now which
that tells me that's cia
rebecca says it's [ __ ] up that the
taliban got a wi-fi signal from the
torabor mountains in afghanistan in
2002. but you guys have issue c yeah
that's what i keep saying i'm like look
this is the 21st century
like and we're right we're only a few
miles outside of [ __ ] orlando florida
every [ __ ] from new york is
moving here city in you know the united
states and the fact that we're having
this much trouble like doing a live
stream and i've like turned down we're
you know i'm not doing hd or nothing
like that
um so i don't really know
honestly i think it's like you said
because we have these the connection out
here that's tied into the hoa anybody
try like two or three other ones because
that actually the um the satellite one
hughes net that wasn't the first one we
did we the first one we did was
centurylink
and that was completely useless
uh that did not work at all and i just i
had that for like a few days and i'm
just like i call them like [ __ ] this
it's like absolutely not working yeah
and uh so then we got hughes net which
worked okay for just you know low data
[ __ ] but when you tried to stream it
didn't work at all yeah
and uh so then we got so then so then
somebody told us oh the hoa
has their own wi-fi
and it was actually much better and it
usually does actually work pretty good
but it's just really
spotty like it'll like it'll go for
hours and hours and then all of a sudden
it just starts like shutting off people
are in there bitching
oh well you know
i don't know if it's bitching or not
it's hard to tell because i can't hear
the tell the voice
oh yeah all those dots all those
thoughts on the [ __ ]
on twitch it made all the gamers mad and
then this and that this is the internet
all right if you want boring [ __ ] you
got tv get on damn television all the
boring g-rated [ __ ] you can find is
right [ __ ] there
me and jenny grew up in the wild west of
the internet
back before anybody knew
you didn't even know what the internet
was you could buy drugs off the internet
[ __ ] when i when i first got on it you
haven't delivered to your house you
could buy stolen [ __ ] over [ __ ] ebay
you could hire a hit man you could hire
a hit man over [ __ ] it was the wild
well i mean you still can't it's just
it's just you have to kind of like not
that i would know but
no those those platforms don't exist for
gamers they don't exist for all this
other [ __ ]
yeah if it's not making money it
shouldn't exist that that's the that is
the law of the [ __ ] universe and when
you see these platforms cutting their
own money flows off and cutting their
own popularity off cia
cia
that's the only explanation the empty
album right here i'm yelling at you
right here central intelligence he's
yelling like right in my ear
it's the cops
that's the only explanation it's some
kind of fbi or cia [ __ ] intelligence
gathering [ __ ] platform
yeah everybody else would go yeah yeah
get them on there yeah we're making
[ __ ] 70 billion dollars this year
woohoo
but when but when the company goes oh no
we have to be moral and
cia
cia although it is kind of funny to me
how many people just like watch videos
of like girls butts bobbing up yeah
that's like really funny cat videos and
[ __ ] well now i'll watch cat videos so
i'll watch like just videos of like just
cats laying around or falling asleep or
something and then they'll say that it's
inappropriate
this is an inappropriate for our
platform you're not here to make money
then as soon as you say that i don't
believe you
you know
because the only thing that is
appropriate is making money
if i honed a [ __ ] platform i would
want every booty in the [ __ ] universe
on the platform i want all the money i
want all the popularity all the people
all the [ __ ] i want every bit of
controversy they're gonna be talking
about me all the time i'd be at the top
of that we're gonna ban this
if they're not saying we got to ban this
there's something wrong with you and
you're just conforming i would want to
be
totally controversial all the time and
make all the money
all of it
but
i would be like pt barnum you know he
knew how to [ __ ] run [ __ ] all right i
don't know what's wrong with this the
only the only it must be intelligence
agencies that's the only explanation
well yeah i mean i'm not a big person i
don't really like um just courting
controversy for the sake of it or trying
to get attention for the sake oh i would
because well no well let me finish what
i was going to say um because a lot of
it's just like stupid edge lordy kind of
[ __ ] and i don't like that um but if
you're trying to make money yeah that's
probably the way to go about it but i
mean i wouldn't want to do that just
because i don't that's not really what
you're making it personalized
you wouldn't want to do it okay which
okay i understand that but if i owned a
platform i would want to do it i
wouldn't even be on the platform the
platform would be out there maybe yeah
you would just encourage it they
wouldn't even know my [ __ ] name
yeah you know what i mean they wouldn't
even know yeah because for some reason i
mean i'm not one of those people so you
know i get it but it's i don't like
relate oh i get it i would i would
monetize it i'm just no what i'm saying
is that personally yeah i don't really
like all this stupid uh manufactured
drama and outrage and all that kind of
stuff to me it's just really transparent
and it's really stupid but it's money
and well i know i know that that's what
i'm trying to say okay please let me
finish what i'm saying
it's like
i swear to god in all the years we've
been together i don't think i've ever
finished a single [ __ ]
but that's not what i'm saying that's
not what i'm saying i'm just saying
personally
um that's not really i don't like to
watch videos doing that i don't like
it's boring to me
but
uh for whatever reason people seem to
love that and so yeah if you want to
make money that's what you got to do you
have to like court all this stupid
outrage and controversy which to me like
i said is really boring but okay like i
guess people like that um zach says you
mentioned glasses earlier i was born
prematurely so my eyes are [ __ ] up one
is lazy and i have less area i can see
out of that one versus the other one
that sucks man yeah and it's just kind
of like and honestly
it's almost kind of like i guess